ما اسمك سارة سارة وأنت
من أيرلندا ما هي الدروس التي
تعلمتها من غزة وأهل
غزة من الشهر الماضي، الشيء الذي
لاحظته هو مدى مساهمة الإسلام في
مساعدة الناس على تجاوز هذا
الوقت العصيب، ما مدى مساهمة الإسلام في اجتياز هذا الوقت العصيب؟  لقد
ساعد الناس على اجتياز هذا
الوقت العصيب ومدى
إيمان الناس الذي يبقيهم مستمرين والقوة
التي يمنحهم إياها وهذا
شيء أنا معجب به حقًا، لذا
فأنت معجب بعقيدة الإسلام نعم
وقوة الناس لطيف حقًا
ما تفعله  قل ولكن أيضًا كيف
أثرت كل هذه الأحداث عليك داخل
نفسك، هل غيرت أي وجهات نظر أو
آراء لك حول العالم من
حولك أم حسنًا، إنه نوع من آه أنا آه لقد كنت
أفكر كثيرًا في
الجمهورية الأيرلندية والصراع الذي  لقد كان
لدينا الحكومة الإنجليزية
واحتلال الإنجليز في أيرلندا منذ
800 عام ويمكنني أن أرسم الكثير من أوجه
التشابه بين ذلك وأه ما
يحدث في فلسطين في الوقت الحالي وقد
ظهر بالفعل أود أن أقول
الأيرلندي الجمهوري  وأنا وأه جلبنا
الكثير من الفخر الوطني حول أه
بلدي بالنسبة لي وأه نعم، لدي الكثير
من الفخر بشعوب العالم فقط لأنهم
اجتمعوا معًا والبدء في
ما هو مهم حسنًا، شكرًا لك، ما كان
اسمك سارة سارة شكرًا  لك
وقتك، أتمنى لك يومًا سعيدًا، سعدت بلقائك